hi I'm Rami Malek I am Charlie Hunnam
and we are gonna be doing the wired
auto-completed interview check it out
they are they are I mean I don't even
know if you have to rip the first one
off how Charlie Hunnam is a question I
ask myself every day if you figure it
out let me know
without further ado how how is how is
Charlie on them Charlie Hunnam is
unpredictable do you like that
mysterious mysterious leave it peaked
he'll go how to pronounce charlie cumin
no I say Hunnam it isn't really a silly
name oh it's Charlie how did show you
how to prepare for King Arthur you know
I read some books that did some push-ups
and I was about it that it yes let's do
it
how was China discovered mmm do you know
this story the real story no no tell us
your story how are you discovered I was
at film school I was in a shoe shop and
New Castle on Christmas Eve drunk and a
lady was staring at me so I blew her
kiss across the store and she was a
production manager of a children's TV
show called Byker Grove and she said
have you ever thought about being an
actor and she gave me a part in that
show and I got myself an agent and that
is that sorry about that
[Laughter]
what color around me Malik sighs hmm
you've been staring it to independence
on your mood darling you know they're
normally the color of beauty
what height yeah five foot eleven that's
great
it's very fairly honest what it was
Ronnie Malik's first movie I don't know
I mean it's on its you can google it
right yeah okay what is runnin Aki we
just had lunch what did I eat salad and
sushi there you go here we go
what is what hecka does rami malek have
this one people google that a bit uh-huh
I do daily engineer got to keep up you
can actually go into two barber shops
and ask for the hunt hunan what's
Charlie doing now you answered that one
this well I'm answering it as I speak
yeah you know just Wes doing this
Charlie Hunnam voice che Hans Instagram
I don't have Instagram because social
media is for suckers
what is China's nationality British what
will Charlie how to do next
you never know ridiculous Charlie Hunnam
look like now here's where we Malik
singing mmm-hmm are you singing always
singing yes probably not British mmm
must be doing something right yeah
mission accomplished is Ronnie Mac
single now that's clearly you rejigged
the order question nothing wouldn't you
like to know
Oh a gentleman never tells his rami
malek related to saying Maliki yeah
that's my cousin and you spelled it
wrong his malik related to bruno mars
also also a cousin you meant with Mars
instead of Malik I don't know it's
worked out for my finger how old you
don't want to answer that gentleman
never tells
how much you Charlie Hunnam beard that's
the that's the question all I know is
that it takes 45 minutes in the morning
- how to meet Charlie Hunnam I think
this is as close as your added Charlie
Hunnam become famous to being in films
who is hi I'm Alex mother your mother in
it my mom yeah who did Ryan my brains to
the Emmys whew that was my cousin Mary
love her next just my mouth look like my
Ma's finally according to google is
Charlie Hunnam single British American
British answer is yes Wow why would
people ask that is Charlie Hunnam a
vegetarian vegetarian jacent I'm
flexitarian go to high school did you go
to honey school I didn't go to high
school where as I didn't where is he
from where am i from I'm from Los
Angeles California born and bred not
British unfortunately we'll have you